Democratic divided on full display over
the weekend as some in the party
continued to push for impeachment while
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi urges caution
the president however says he's not
really worried about it so I'm listening
to you you're not worried about being
prosecuted once you leave office it did
nothing wrong judge did nothing wrong
there was no collusion you don't even
hear Russia mentioned anymore
Russia's not mentioned now it's all
about obstruct obstruction of what they
built up a phony crime they hired a man
that hated Trump he hired 18 people that
were Democrats that hated Trump some of
them contributed to Clinton's campaign
Pelosi holding firm still not wanting to
rush into impeachment proceedings I
don't think there's anything more
divisive we can do than to impeach a
president of the United States and so
you have to handle it with great care
has to be about the truth and the facts
to take you to whatever decision has to
be there it should by no means to be
done politically you shouldn't impeach
politically but you shouldn't not engage
politically and yet freshman
congresswoman Alexandria Kazmir Cortes
publicly airing her grievances about
Nancy Pelosi refusal to impeach Trump so
how real is that progressive frustration
that speaker Pelosi has said at least so
far and she seems to be really holding a
line that she's not ready to do that I
think it's quite real and I believe that
there is a very real animus and desire
to make sure that we are that that we
are holding this president to account
one let me ask you about how Alex Daniel
Kazmir Cortes she's from a very blue
district she doesn't have to worry about
her own re-election and I think she was
kind of setting down a marker there that
the progressive wing of the caucus the
Nancy Pelosi is trying to guide and lead
is not going to worry that much about
the other districts because they really
want to see the president held to
account in their view right but I think
there's an important distinction I think
Nancy Pelosi is making is a big
difference between impeaching President
Trump and removing him from office and I
sometimes think when I hear Alexandria
Ocasio
to speak it is out up just like a fury
at Trump and it really does represent
close to 70 percent of the Democratic
base Dana that woods like the seam
impeach but again there's a big
difference between impeachment and
actually going through and having the
Senate convict the president and remove
him from office so I think that you know
it's a matter of understanding and this
comes back to where you started this
that Nancy Pelosi is focused on 2020 not
only on keeping control of the house and
retaining her speakership but also on
defeating President Trump and she looks
at a lot of those districts that you've
highlighted to our viewers repeatedly
over the last few weeks and says hey a
lot of these Democrats who won in 2018
in the midterms were people who came
from what I would call purple maybe even
reddish districts and I think Pelosi is
just a really smart political player
Pelosi has Jesse more of a hold on her
caucus and I think Boehner or Ryan ever
had but if the AOC s of Boehner and Ryan
had a hold on and so now like if the
progressive decide to make their own
sort of house freedom caucus could there
be more problems for her there could be
but she's not going to impeach because
she doesn't have the votes they only
have about thirty right now in the house
and what do they have 200 and some plus
Democrats in the house and sixty-one
percent of the American people don't
want impeachment that's in the Q poll
there totally miss reading the public
they had these impeachment rallies all
across the country over the weekend
total bust no one ever even really
showed I don't even know that exactly so
and you're in the business that's why so
the the whole news cycle is driven by
impeachment through the press the press
wants to book Democrats who want to
impeach the president they invite them
on and they say impeach and then they do
a segment on it then the media runs a
poll on impeachment and then they do a
segment on the poll then the media asks
Donald Trump about impeachment he says
that they do a segment they ask the
Democrats running for president about
impeachment then they do a segment so
it's this this self-perpetuating
news cycle about impeachment but it's in
a bubble and the bubble is constantly
shrinking because CNN and MSNBC cease
ratings are going down so big and the
rest of the country is like I'm just
gonna go get a beer out in the porch I
don't care anymore
did you get a beer out on the porch this
weekend C Schmidt protest we didn't know
about I wish you know I can throw a
protest yeah I'll let me start with a
small picture and then I'm gonna move on
to the big picture this is gonna be
great the small picture begins with this
do you ever get in a fight with your
spouse with little or no reason why why
do you do that because you can because
things are good both of you are healthy
the kids are fine the finances seem to
be okay that allows you actually to
bicker right but trust me when you know
when one person isn't is ill or another
person is in financial peril there is no
bickering because you have a huge
concern going on now that goes to the
big picture we are living in an amazing
time where that we have to broaden the
definition of news to include stuff that
isn't actually real news so people are
complaining about stuff that may happen
not is happening right there is no
impeachment these are what if arguments
as opposed to what are arguments we have
had this shift to what - what if
arguments over the last like I'd say
last two years in the past the wit
issues what are war terror poverty
unemployment crime they still exist but
you cannot deny the direction that the
world is going in in solving a lot of
these issues especially Isis North Korea
joblessness now we're talking about
tainted alcohol and Dominican Republic
Trump's personality in Chinese tariffs
America in 2019 are like Michael Jordan
circa 1990 suffering from a hangnail
that's what America's problems are it
has a hangnail headed into the roaring
2020 the Dems are kids playing in the
backyard because mommy and daddy built
them a nice safe home with a great
sandbox and a swing set mommy and daddy
is trumps America safe serene and
prosperous the kids aren't worried about
crime they're not worried about
kidnapping they're not worried about
wages because they're going up so they
get to play all day in there impeachment
backyard one of the polls Emily this we
can't think might have been ours it said
that a toad
of 27% of people want to see impeachment
and I saw a news report last night not
on our network that was basically saying
like wow this is really growing I mean
it's 27% of the country and there was
also a 3% margin of error so it
literally could be as low as 24 I think
everyone made such good points
thank you yes even one yes so I'll start
with you one you may that was so
excellent is the notion that where does
the fury stop essentially for these
progressive left Democrats who are
shouting about impeachment that doesn't
equal removal and we all know similar to
the mower report and what happened that
the ripple effect is just that and that
at every layer of the ripple there's
like well there's going to be another
one well well this will this will this
it's always a step further and what
struck me about a OCS clearer delusion
and that kind of petulance petulant
quality is the fact that you know she
honestly believes as she said that they
risk losing the presidency the next one
if unless they elect a candidate that
believes in true transformational
qualities for every US citizen and
literally thinks that's true and I just
spent 10 days driving around the South
six states and Texas with Fox with six
dates yeah most states anyway that's not
what people were talking about by any
means and I think again it kind of
speaks to the level of that the 16-year
old teenager having the loudest voice
that the media is picking up and
resounding in the echo chamber chamber
final point that poll also interestingly
said that 40% of independents however
support impeachment so I do think that's
something that we should watch you only
talked about his point you didn't talk
about anybody else mine's a given that
it was President Trump who agreed with
her which was a surprise delicious I
told you they're like two peas in a pod
you put them in a room together they're
gonna be fast friends and also Dana it
was the NBC poll that had 27 uh the Fox
News poll had like 43% impeach and
remove and 7% impeach only 50%